so habe ich lange kein Adventskalender
mehr gesehen die essen
nee liebe Kinder es niemals irgendein
Verpackungsmaterial
warenhinweis von eurer Tante Vanessa
den kriegt man nicht raus ohne eine
Sauerei zu machen
als dir viel Zeit drin daraus kann man
also die kann man so mit einer Schnur
zusammen denken und dann hat man wie so
eine lichtfreie Licht Lichterkette ich
freue mich ein bisschen zu doll über
diesen Adventskalender hallo hier ist
Vanessa und heute packen wir den Karls
Erdbeerhof Adventskalender aus aber was
ist Karls Erdbeerhof ja die sind bekannt
in Berlin und Brandenburg auf jeden Fall
für diese riesengroßen Erdbeeren aus
denen Erdbeeren verkauft werden und
Spargel oder und Karls Erdbeerhof hat
Karls Erlebnisdorf und da gibt es eine
Achterbahn und ganz viel zum Erleben für
Kinder für Groß und Klein und dann
gibt's Verkaufsstände
Freizeitpark okay aber wo ist kalt also
Karls Erdbeerhof liegt so über Potsdam
da ist der die Erlebniswelt die Eiswelt
die haben es verstanden die dachten sich
ja wir können Erdbeeren anbauen aber wir
könnten auch noch eine ganze Welt
drumherum bauen
auf dem Online-Shop und alles mögliche
und dieses Jahr auch ihren eigenen
Adventskalender ich weiß nicht was ich
erwartet habe aber er ist zuckersüß von
Design also wirklich so weihnachtlich
wie die kleinen Wichtel hier alles
machen und die Erben verarbeiten Erwin
und die Schokolade und bevor ihr denkt
ich stecke mit der erdbeermafia unter
einer Decke dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses Videos
nicht gesponsert ja ich ich weiß auch
gar nicht ach so den Preis noch ne das
ist auf jeden Fall Match haben wir hier
für einen Preis dieser Kalender kostet
69 €, also es gibt diese Adventskalender
ich habe den hier oben und dann gibt's
noch die anderen zwei für 39,49 €. ich
habe mir den luxuskalender geholt ja und
wie immer weiß ich absolut nicht was
mich hier erwartet ich war letztes Jahr
auf so einem kürbishof und da hatten sie
mittlerweile jedes Produkt mit Kürbis
Kürbis Bonbons Kürbis Nudeln Kürbis
Likör Kürbis Seife also ich bin gespannt
hier gibt's einmal das Logo Karls so
Kinder und jetzt schauen wir mal ins
Türchen Nummer 1 ja es kann sein dass
ich jetzt einfach ein Kinderkanal werde
hallo Kinder wow hier muss man noch ich
suchen wir sind über diese kleinen
weißen zahlen und dann findet man die
Zahlen nicht das fühlt sich an wie
früher
guckt euch den an das ist das ist wie so
ein perfekter Kinder
Kalle weiß als Kind hätte ich mir alles
ganz genau angeschaut was da so passiert
und jetzt geht die erdbeerparty los
selbst
gemacht weißt du was ich in diesem
Kalender erwartet hätte Kaffee Arabica
Kaffee mit Vanille und Karamell
Geschmack also Kaffee und da haben sie
noch Aroma hinzugefügt ein wintercafé
und jetzt werde ich nur die Preise
nachschauen wenn sie mit einem größeren
Warenwert werben und das tun sie nicht
also werde ich da jetzt nicht jede
Preise nachgucken ob es sich Lohn für 69
€ man genau das bekommt weil ihr seht
das sind kleine Packungen und
wahrscheinlich ist das extra dafür
abgepackt also dieser Kalender verströmt
so einen krassen Duft von 100
verschieden
ziemlich schade das Motiv kaputt zu
machen fühle ich mich immer wie ein
kleines Kind Nummer zwei
auf sowas habe ich gehofft oh jetzt
gehen wir Tommy Fruchtsaft
erdbeer-gummibonbons Erdbeer pur Leute
Maskottchen ist ein erdbeers lustig oh
toll guckt mal Leute in dieser Erdbeere
sieht man einfach wie Hand gemacht das
ist das da noch so diese 14 hängt Zucker
kosesirup Erdbeersaft Gelatine nicht
vegetarisch und echtes Kamin also oder
Läuse
sind sehr lecker was kostet denn so eine
Tüte bei denen interessieren 130 Gramm
für 3 Euro gut ich meine Haribo Preise
können sie nicht haben ne Nummer drei
also aber dann ist es wirklich kein
kinderkalender ne obwohl ich dann seit
meinte das ist so ein schöner wird so
ein Kind mit Kaffee anfangen normal drei
ich glaube das ist kein Kind oh das ist
definitiv kein kinderkalender
erdbeerwein oh das würde ich mir aber
für ein ganz besonderen Moment
aufbewahren
ich kann gerade noch nichts trinken weil
ich habe Trinkpause aber der schmeckt
bestimmt sehr sehr lecker ich hoffe das
Video ist auch für mich Berliner und so
spannend ich weiß nicht inwiefern man
Karls Erdbeerhof kennt ich finde es auf
jeden Fall toll was kann man noch aus
Erdbeeren machen es jetzt mal ernsthaft
Popcorn mit Erdbeergeschmack aber deren
Verpackung sieht man eigentlich ohne
Schere aus da wird jetzt einfach alles
mit Erdbeeren drin sein
ich weiß nicht ob man Erdbeeren Popcorn
braucht ja schmeckt schon ganz
interessant aber die wollen wirklich
alles mit Erdbeeren machen also die
Gummibärchen haben total Sinn gemacht
ist Popcorn nicht so nee fünf na was
wird da drin sein natürlich Erdbeer
vanille-traum ist das eine Marmelade die
Fruchtaufstrich
muss aber ein krasser Vanille Geschmack
aber das nicht echte Vanille drin das
nur Vanillearoma drin aber schade wenn
natürlich im Vanillegeschmack die
Schreiben erdbeerfruchtaufstrich mit
natürlichem Vanillegeschmack und dann
ist aber Vanille nicht in den Zutaten
sondern da steht nur Aroma das ist ja
dann nicht natürlich Vanille oder dann
schreiben die doch immer mit echter
Bonbon Vanille ganz schön kleine Portion
roaste den Karls Erdbeerhof okay Leute
Nikolaus meinte der Karls Erdbeerhof
interessiert sich für Nikolaus die haben
die Kunst dass wir machen alles aus
einer Sache perfektioniert gerade Pulver
ja das ist Erdbeer badepulver das riecht
ganz schön intensiv ich will das ich
will das wirklich kein Problem
riecht ihr auch mal dran
man kann also mit den Erdbeeren auch
badepulver machen im Winter so viel an
der Erdbeere zu riechen ist irgendwie
auch komisch nicht jetzt Erdbeeren der
Sommer kommt
[Musik]
okay ich sag als nächstes ist Erdbeer
Senf drin und
und jetzt kommt ein Knoblauch Dip
kräftiger Knoblauch Dip Löffel Knoblauch
Dip mit etwas heißem Wasser aufgießen
mit 200 g Creme fraiche verrühren und 15
Minuten ziehen lassen mit etwas fein
gehackter oder geraspelter Salatgurke
verfeinern lecker es ist schon alles so
so cutest Zeug ne wenn ich das so im
Laden sehen würde würde ich mir denken
oh cool das ist so in so einem
Reagenzglas drin ist total süß verpackt
das nehme ich mit okay jetzt ist hier
Erdbeer Senf drin
Kendall Factory ein Senf aber eine
erdbeerkerze riecht nach Erdbeere was
soll ich euch sagen gemacht von der
Kerne Factory irgendeine Kerze wurde
schon mal von der candle factory
Timo verbrennt unser Haus
brennt irgendwo Rauchmelder
Hauptsache meine erste Vermutung ist
Timo der uns alle umbringt letztes Jahr
hatte ich irgendwo einfach wieder
weitermachen letztes Jahr hatte ich
irgendwo ein Adventskalender wurde auch
von der canofactory gemacht ich habe
das gelesen okay Nummer 9 ich glaube
jetzt kommt der Erdbeer Senf in der
Nummer 9 ist der erste Senf drin und an
dieser Stelle könnt ihr euch jetzt bitte
den Erdbeertee oder sowas holen oder
Erdbeereis damit ihr nachfühlen könnt
wie es hier gerade riecht normal 9 das
Motto wurde hier nicht ganz durchgezogen
karlseife Waldbeere handgemacht in
Rövershagen
richtig gut die riecht so toll und sieht
wirklich auch schön aus boah die benutze
ich sofort weil du so einen
seifenschnitz Video auf meinem Hase mehr
Kanal machen ich liebe diese
seifenschnitz Videos wo die dann immer
so richtig fette Blöcke so
durchschneiden ich bin erst zufrieden
wenn ich mein Erdbeer Senf habe Nummer
10 Bonbon mit Himbeer Vanillegeschmack
und natürlich echtes Kamin wenn wir da
keine Läuse drin gepackt haben dann
schmeckt es doch nicht ich bin jetzt
nicht so ein Fan von diesen richtigen
Zuckerbonbons dann kauft diese Bonbons
auch eigentlich nur noch aus Deko Zweck
oder das schmeckt echt nicht so schlecht
ihr müsst auch überlegen wie kritisch
kann ich so einen Kalender aufmachen die
ist von Karls Erdbeerhof natürlich lohnt
sich das preislich alles nicht wenn das
kriegt man alles irgendwo günstiger aber
es ist alles so cute aber nicht so süß
wie mein Erdbeeren Senf winterlöffel
Eierlikör Marzipan Zimt was ist das
Löffel Eierlikör Creme mit Marzipan
enthält eier und Sahne und deshalb 15%
Alkohol
wenn ihr wisst wozu man das ist und was
das eigentlich sein soll dann schreibt
es bitte in die Kommentare willst du ein
Erdbeer Gummibärchen und Stativ würde
ich gerne haben Halbzeit für unseren
Kalender wenn es kein Erdbeer Senf gibt
dann muss es doch wenigstens erdbeerkäse
geben oder das ist erdbeerkäse
natürliche Nummer 12 ist
wintersempf ich wusste es doch kommt ja
ich habe gesagt ich habe gesagt
fruchtig mit Erdbeere nee also so eine
richtige kleine probier Portion junge
ich glaube da kommt kein Erdbeer Senf
mehr und die haben es richtig gut
gemacht nächste Halbzeit wir sehen
Weihnachten quasi schon vor der Tür wir
machen das 13 Türchen auf und dann
Ritter befindet sich
oft ein viereckiges Schokoladenstück
regenschokolade Vollmilch das war eine
Zeit lang auch so ein Ding oder dass man
an so einem Stiel Schokolade hatte und
sich das in warmer Milch dann aufgelöst
hat und es dann Kakao sein sollte aber
es war nie so lecker vor allem ohne
Kakaopulver und den ganzen Kram schmeckt
das auch gar nicht so intensiv naja ein
Stück Schokolade die haben das
hergestellt 14 da muss doch jetzt
wahrscheinlich ein Frucht Tee drin sein
ich habe es erraten Erdbeer Sahne
aromatisierte fruchtemischung mit
Erdbeer-Sahne Geschmack ihr könnt nicht
glauben wie viel Tee ich gerade zu Hause
habe meistens kauft eine neue Packung
und denke mir so ja aber ich trinke
gerade auch ganz schön viel Tee ja und
das mache ich dann für drei Tage und
dann vergesse ich wieder das Tee
überhaupt existiert aber cool also jetzt
hätte ich mal Lust auf was mit
Erdbeergeschmack 15 die Erdbeer Nektar
es hängt hier an dieser Stelle fest
trinken man das so es ist ja nicht wie
ein Limone das probiere ich jetzt mal
doch jetzt lass ich mir nicht nehmen oh
mein Gott ich muss schon wieder an meine
Großeltern denken oh Gott
und zwar hat mein Opa immer Erdbeeren
eingelegt in so Einmachgläsern dann bin
ich als Kind immer da war habe ich so
weiche braune komische Erdbeeren aus
einem Glas gegessen und ich fand das
eigentlich mal ganz geil aber auch
irgendwie gar nicht geil das schmeckt
genauso
also zum pur trinken nicht weil wenn man
sich hier schön Eiswürfel und Selter
rein macht
okay ich rate irgendwas mit
Erdbeergeschmack
erdbeergelee-traum was ist da drin
Erdbeersaft Zucker Geliermittel keine
Läuse die ist so geil
ich glaube der ist ein bisschen drüber
das schmeckt so ein bisschen verbrannt
als ob die das zu lange erhitzt haben
jetzt gefällt mir jetzt nicht so ich
brauche mal irgendwas herzhaftes
Erdbeeren sind so süß kriegt ein
zuckerschaum aber Hintertürchen 17 wird
was herzhaftes sein an natürlich Erdbeer
rumtraum wo können wir noch Alkohol
reinmachen Erdbeeren Zucker Heidelbeeren
Sauerkirschen da ist gar kein rum drin
das Rumaroma finde ist kein Fan von Rum
deswegen werde ich das nicht mal
probieren komm schon Nummer 18 was
salziges da steht Salz ja ich habe was
salziges bekommen Leute ich habe was
salziges bekommen
Ostsee Salz sommer Sonne Salz und mehr
liebst du nicht den Geschmack von Salz
auf deinen Lippen nach einem heißen
Sommer ostsee-tag hier steht ein Preis
drauf wir haben wieder Originalgröße
reingebaut 450 sieht aber also ja das
ist Ostsee Salz irgendwie ist der
Gedanke ich meine meersalz ist auch Salz
aus dem Meer ich verstehe es aber bei
Ostsee Salz muss ich irgendwie an meinen
eigenen Badetag denken und das mein Salz
dann halt mit Menschen in Kontakt
gekommen ist die sich da drin gebadet
haben ich denke nicht dass das so sein
wird aber irgendwie
komisch wenn jemand von euch Experte ist
warum Salz aus dem Meer natürlich
absolut klasse ist und gar nicht blöd
schreibt gerne in die Kommentare weil
gerade denke ich an die ganzen Leute die
sich ausziehen Baden so jetzt habe ich
gerade gesagt ich will was salziges ne
da kann Salz jetzt möchte ich was mit
jetzt kommt was mit Zimt oh
ich bin einfach Jenny Wintertraum
Erdbeer Vanille Zimt
kniet vor eurer Adventskalender Türchen
rate Göttin okay jetzt wird drin sein
scheiße jetzt ist der Druck groß jetzt
kommt was mit Schokolade
okay ich muss Lotto spielen okay
es ist zwar ohne Palmöl aber es ist
jetzt auch nicht zu dass die beste Creme
aller Zeiten oh gott
muss ich sagen was in 21 drin ist ne
irgendwas mit Schoko und dann ist das
Schokocreme drin ähm jetzt hatten wir
schon alles ja jetzt
kommt ein herzhafter Snack ich sage ein
herzhafter Snack geht das ist falsch
jetzt kommt Bonbons ah okay na klar
leider liege ich dieses Mal nicht
richtig ich habe schon gedacht ich habe
irgendwelche übernatürlichen Kräfte
erdbeertraum also
Erdbeermarmelade ach so ich dachte wir
hatten das schon mal aber das war ein
Erdbeer vanille-traum und das ist ein
erdbeertraum ich rate nicht mehr davon
kann man wirklich nie genug haben
Glühwein gewürzt ey das sieht schon so
cool aus in diesen Reagenzgläsern ne ich
bin ich bin so ein Konsum auf einmal
wenn ich das dann irgendwann sehe dann
bin ich so oh hier das können wir
mitnehmen das kann man gut verschenken
toll einfaches packaging okay vorletztes
Türchen und hier ist erdbeerkäse drin
nein
Erdbeer Schokolade Schokolade mit
Erdbeeren wir
also das erdbeerzeug schmeckt gut aber
die Schokolade es tut mir so leid kalt
Erdbeerhof die Schokolade schmeckt nur
nach Fett Zucker und also ihr seid halt
nicht Lindner aber keep going
und nun kommt der wunderbare Moment das
ist das 24 Türchen und zeigen die
Erdbeeren schon aus den Ohren raus aber
trotzdem freuen wir uns das letzte
Türchen aufzumachen na das ist mein 21
natürlich
verbinde diesen kleinen Bärchen auf
jeden Fall hier nicht mit Gin ne also
diesen Karls Erlebnishof aber es
funktioniert anscheinend hergestellt in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist auf jeden
Fall ein passendes 24 Türchen und nun
stellen wir uns wieder der
allerwichtigsten Frage ja wie finden wir
denn jetzt find das ist ein perfekter
Rentner Adventskalender und gerade wenn
deine Eltern kalt Erdbeerhof noch kennt
10 von 10 also Ostsee Salz ne ein paar
süße Erdbeer Gummibärchen Kaffee mit
Vanille Geschmack was das ist dann für
die Großeltern mal sowas freches ne
erdbeerkalender übersehen was ich
erwartet haben er hat auch eine tolle
Auswahl sind aber am Ende des Tages
immer noch 69 €. schon viel Geld und es
ist sehr viel Marmelade ich muss mir da
jetzt mal ganz kurz hin ich habe 69 nur
dafür bezahlt glaube ich finde den gut
wenn ich Karls Erdbeerhof Fan wäre also
so random wenn ich den jetzt so random
bekomme hätte dann
hätte ich gedacht okay da hat er die
Konkurrenz die Nase vorn was
Preis-Leistung angeht aber das hat
irgendwie noch so ein emotionalen Wert
und es ist so süß Hand verpackt und es
ist einfach was anderes als diese Massen
großen Firmen obwohl ich mir auch nicht
so sicher bin wie groß kann als
Erdbeerhof mittlerweile ist wenn sie ihn
Freizeitpark haben so Kinder und jetzt
habt ihr den mal von innen gesehen und
jetzt abschalten